let's begin by talking about what
happened what actually happened as far
as we know at this point on Monday
afternoon a 30 year old mentally ill
vagrant named Jordan Neely who also
happens to be black boarded a subway
train in New York City and began
harassing the passengers Witnesses
described nearly as hostile and erratic
he was apparently yelling and carrying
on screaming that he's quote ready to
die and quote doesn't mind going to jail
and quote will hurt anyone on this train
um this was not Neely's first foray into
this territory he was a man with 44
prior arrests with charges ranging from
assault to drug-related offenses he also
had an open warrant for a felony assault
dating back to 2021 that was an open
warrant at the time that this all
happened multiple people on social media
have since reported that their own uh
you know they've had their own alleged
run-ins with Neely who according to
these reports was known to harass and
threaten passengers in other words Neely
was yet another violent repeat criminal
who had been essentially granted free
Reign Over the subway system where crime
has skyrocketed over the last few years
as commuters are frequently accosted
mugged assaulted even raped and killed
this is not just the case in the New
York City subway system but in the city
as a whole and in major cities all
across the country as we know but on the
F train on Monday afternoon some of the
passengers decided that they had enough
rather than sitting there and waiting
for Neely to lash out violently uh
waiting for him to make good on his
explicit threats to hurt people hoping
that if he starts physically attacking
people that you know maybe they'll be
able to intervene before anyone is
seriously hurt or killed instead of that
a few passengers stepped up to do what
was necessary at least three Good
Samaritans restrained nearly one man
who's a white man and a former Marine
had Neely in a choke hold another a
black man was holding down his arms they
held him down for several minutes
because there was no law enforcement
immediately on the scene and they were
in this enclosed claustrophobic
environment and uh they they worked they
weren't going to do that and then just
let him go
so they held on to him eventually Neely
lost Consciousness and died
police took at least one of the
passengers who restrained him the white
man the Marine into custody for
questioning they released him sometime
later without pressing charges
now what you should know is that there
were over 10 people I think there's 11
people in total who were killed on the
New York City subway just last year
along with many more accosted and
assaulted
uh you don't know any of their names do
you
many more fell victim to violent crime
all over the city over 400 people were
murdered just in 2022 alone just in New
York City
you probably don't know any of their
names either
the problem for those victims is that in
a great many of those cases the
perpetrators were black
but as we know violence carried out by
black people no matter the race of the
victim is not useful to the media or the
Democrat Party which means that those
victims must remain nameless and
faceless
but in this case the man who had Jordan
Neely in a headlock was whites and that
is the only detail the left needs
that's it they don't need anything else
because they can make up the rest or
they can they can massage the facts a
little bit to get them to the point
where they want them
the only absolute fact that they need
and that they usually can't lie about is
the racial component
hundreds of black people are killed
every single year year after year a
trail of violence and death and misery
that is only getting worse over time not
better victim after victim day after day
after day and the left says nothing
does nothing
does not care does not make Martyrs or
Heroes out of any of these victims does
not demand that we say their names
they wait
and they wait and they wait
and they have to wait a while
until eventually they they come across
the extremely rare occurrence where a
black man dies allegedly at the hands of
a white man and that is when they leap
into action taking full advantage which
is what has happened here
so protesters uh in response to Jordan
Neely's death swarmed the uh the New
York City subway system yesterday
demanding Justice for Jordan Neely the
media went into full George Floyd mode
blatantly racializing the incident while
in real time and we could see this
happening in real time they started to
reshape
uh Jordan Neely himself into something
other than the violent career criminal
that he actually was so we could
actually if you were on social media
yesterday you could see this happening
in real time as they began to sort of
figure out who they want to make this
guy into and in this case it appears
that Neely sometimes dressed like
Michael Jackson when he was on the
subway and he would perform
unsolicited dance routines
you know uh for hoping for tips from
people and this is a fact that
as far as I'm concerned if anything
makes him even less sympathetic but but
which the media is using to paint him as
some kind of struggling artist a kind
soul who wished only to bring people joy
and happiness and he just wanted to
dance for people he lived to dance
that's all that's all it was
many headlines have been published
claiming that a white man killed a black
Michael Jackson impersonator that's how
they're referring to him in the
headlines as if this is the most
important detail about him
a Michael Jackson impersonator was
killed not a career criminal not not a
homeless vagrant not a mentally ill
psychopath no not that a Michael Jackson
impersonator
it's it's you know almost as if right
they tackled him to the ground and
choked him out for being a Michael
Jackson impersonator like the impression
they want to give you from the headlines
is that the passengers on the on the
train got annoyed with him dancing
around like Michael Jackson and then
tackle them
which is not what happened at all
Democrat politicians have also been
activated AOC Ayanna Presley uh the
squad you know together have been
leading the Lynch Mob as usual AOC has
been making frantic public statements
demanding an arrest and criminal charges
though uh though of course she doesn't
she doesn't need to wait for any of
those things least of all a conviction
to pass down her own verdict which she
has already done the mayor of New York
City has been to this point
slightly more cautious in his public
response he hasn't come out and actually
said that this was a racist murder not
yet anyway
that's not good enough for AOC
who is now demanding that the mayor
publicly accuse this Marine of murder so
to be clear
this is an elected official demanding
that a citizen who hasn't been arrested
uh or charged be pronounced guilty of
murder
without trial without conviction or
again without even a criminal charge
she along with many others on the left
are openly calling for a public lynching
of a man who has not been officially
accused of committing any crime
the attack on masculinity is no secret
mainstream media demonizes normal
heterosexual and masculine men while
promoting non-masculine behavior and
gender fluidity anybody who dares to
speak out is quickly labeled a homophobe
sexist misogynist and then silenced
notably there are studies coming out
that show testosterone levels have been
declining for decades with a 17 drop
among 60 year olds in 2004 compared to
1987. researchers call these changes
alarming to say the least and that's why
you need to check Black Forest
supplements the Black Forest testostack
is the ultimate solution to help you
reclaim your masculinity it combines the
power of three natural supplements to
help boost your testosterone levels and
improve your overwhelm overall
well-being black four supplements is
dedicated to Bringing bringing back
traditional masculinity and femininity
you can visit blackforestsupplements.com
and use code wall should check out for
10 off your order today don't let
anybody tell you that being strong and
confident is a bad thing that's black
forestsupplements.com promo code Walsh
today the pro-life battle has finally
left DC and it's going to the Grassroots
as one of the largest pro-life
organizations in the world no one's in a
better position than 40 Days for life to
end abortion in a post-rural America
with one million Volunteers in 1500
cities 40 Days for life holds peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities
because of that they actually have a
larger presence in blue States
specifically California former abortion
clinic directors say that these vigils
can cause the abortion no show rate to
go as high as 75 which is detrimental to
their business and thank God for that
these law-abiding vigils have helped
close abortion facilities in San
Francisco Seattle and Chicago they're
also leading the effort in uh the
leading the way in efforts to prevent
pharmacies from dispensing chemical
abortions you can support their work and
check out their locations podcast and
free magazine at 40 daysforlife.com the
fight for life is uh certainly not over
it has entered a new phase but still
deeply important and if you want to
learn more you can go to information get
more information on 40 Days for life at
40daysforlife.com
now it remains to be seen whether
they'll be able to fully repeat their
George Floyd trick with Jordan Neely uh
which you know means riots looting
another great racial Awakening quote
unquote an unjust and politically
motivated trial and conviction Etc
but that is clearly their goal and they
are on their way towards it right now
but as these as these deeply evil forces
set to work to make full use of this
incident and to make another white man
into a sacrificial victim on the altar
of racial Justice
what is the actual truth
right what is the correct response who
is really at fault
well the answer to that last question I
think will give us the answer to the
others and uh to that we can say that
there are two parties responsible
for the death of Jordan Neely
and the first party
we cannot forget is Jordan Neely himself
okay so who's first and foremost to
blame for the fact that Jordan Neely is
dead today well Jordan neelius
he may have been mentally ill
but he's also the only person on the
planet who can directly decide how he
behaves okay there's one person with
direct control over that and it's Jordan
Neely
he's the one who harassed a train full
of passengers who are just trying to get
to or and from work uh he's the one who
announced himself explicitly as a threat
and it threatened to hurt them
he's the one who's lived a life of crime
for at least the past decade
it's his actions that precipitated the
events that led to his death if he had
not chosen to announce himself as a
threat to those around him if he had not
chosen to carry on the way that he did
he would still be alive today
he put the other passengers in a
position of having to choose whether to
gamble with their safety by allowing him
to you know run around screaming waiting
for him to do something violent
or whether they should step in and
subdue him he put them in that position
but it wasn't just him who put them in
that position the other party
responsible is the Democrat Party
um the political leadership of the city
the justice system DA's like Alvin Bragg
in Manhattan who have made the conscious
decision to keep men like Jordan Neely
on the streets to continually release
these people back into the public no
matter how many dozens of crimes they
each commit until the until until the
point that they are either killed
or they kill someone else
that's the way the just system now
operates
commit crime commit crime Crime After
Crime After Crime
keep them on the street until a death
occurs either their death or somebody
else's and actually in the latter case
where they kill somebody else they might
still stay on the streets even after
that
that the only thing that that will
definitely get them on the street off
the street is if they're killed
but that's not that's a decision that
the system has made
Jordan Neely belonged in prison
um or a mental Asylum
he had long ago made it clear that he
had no interest in being a you know a
civilized member of society he was a
danger to his community and to himself
and this had been demonstrated time and
time again
Jordan Neely could not have been clearer
about this
if the system had done what it was
supposed to do if it had gotten him off
the street you know and locked him away
somewhere
he would be alive today
but the left does not want to prosecute
crime because crime is committed in a
racially disproportionate way it is
committed in a racially disproportionate
way
which means that prosecutions and
convictions and incarcerations will
naturally be disproportionate
but the left can't have that so they
would rather let criminals criminals
terrorize you and and your family
in fact it's kind of a win-win for them
because if they refuse to prosecute
criminals
um they can enact their perverse idea of
racial Justice by by keeping these black
criminals on the street and um
because it's only when it comes to
Criminal Justice Reform that's all
they're really concerned about obviously
um and at the same time they can put
honest citizens in a position of having
to make very difficult decisions with
their lives potentially on the line and
then they can exploit those situations
they can send the mob after you know yet
another scapegoat
and use the chaos they've created to
advance their racial narrative
which is why the one man that I will not
blame for this
is the man who is getting all of the
blame right now
now you can argue that it's uh it's not
Wise from a self-preservation standpoint
for anyone especially any white man to
intervene in these kinds of situations
anymore
um while the while the left has
engineered a win-win for themselves
for you it is a lose-lose
now if you decide to get involved either
you get hurt in your attempt to protect
yourself or potentially killed uh in
your attempt to protect yourself and
others or you Prevail in the struggle
and then you find yourself pursued by a
crazed leftist mob calling for your head
and then if you're arrested and charged
you'll find yourself standing before a
New York City jury or a big city jury
somewhere else where your conviction
will have already been decided before
the jury was even selected that's what
AOC is up to right now she wants to
assume she's assuming probably rightly
so that this innocent man is going to be
um
arrested and charged and so she right
now wants she doesn't want to take any
chances she wants to decide the verdict
right now
pollute the jury pool have this man
label the murderer in every headline
so that when the when the trial
eventually comes he's doomed
this makes it extremely dicey to say the
least to play the Good Samaritan role
but it also makes it all the more heroic
the the Marine who at this point but
likely for not much longer remains
nameless is not only not at fault not
only in the rights
but is in fact a hero this was a heroic
action he took he did what the leaders
of his City would not do what the system
refuses to what the police are not
allowed to do anymore in a city like New
York City
he was under no moral obligation nor any
legal obligation to sit silently
obediently while a psychotic criminal
vagrant runs wild threatening and
harassing innocent people
he's not under that obligation this is
an obligation that the left wants to
impose on us they want us to believe
that it is our responsibility to
helplessly submit ourselves to the whims
of every violent scumbag we come across
but it is not so
and so this man took action
he deserves a medal for his actions
in a healthy Society that's what he
would get
we don't live in a healthy Society we
live in a depraved and Confused one
which means tragically I'm afraid that
his reward is likely to be quite
different I'll do it for uh this portion
shows move over to members block you can
become a member today by using Code wall
should check out for two months free on
all annual plans hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed